let's get straight to it should we the
um home secretary is with me here in the
studio of course pretty patel tell us
about this resettlement program good
morning kay so this is absolutely about
our commitment to
people of in afghanistan who are
vulnerable in light of what we are now
seeing with scenes on the ground so this
is effectively a new humanitarian route
a resettlement scheme that obviously is
coming in addition to the work that we
are doing right now
to remove afghan nationals who've worked
with our armed forces and done all sorts
of incredible work alongside the british
government over the last 20 years so
this route will in the first year we are
speaking first of all about the first
year will bring approximately 5 000
people from afghanistan to the united
kingdom we're working through details
the logistics that party partners that
we'll be working through um and the real
details of that will come together over
the next few days does 5 000 this year
reflect accurately the scenes that we've
seen at kabul airport well i think it's
important kay to ensure that we have a
scheme that will deliver
and we have to think very carefully
about the practicalities currently
already and you would have heard from my
colleague ben wallace ben and i have
been working in the defence secretary
and i've been working very close on
bringing back resettling those afghan
nationals who've worked alongside
british forces we'll talk about that
separately so that's one scheme and
that's around five thousand people
that's in fact that's going to be bigger
so importantly with the new humanitarian
route that we are announcing today we
have to ensure that we have clearly all
the support structures um across the
united kingdom so you would have seen
from our announcement we'll be working
with local councils around the country
with the devolved governments as well to
ensure that we can support those people
this isn't just about bringing people
over this is about resettlement
resettling people so that they can begin
a new life in the united kingdom if they
don't do it quickly they might not be
alive well we are working quickly on
this so why not 20 000 all at once
primarily because we cannot accommodate
20 000 people all in one go we have to
have this well actually i spoke to the
canadians last night came they can't
okay so what do they say so i will tell
you now what they've said they have an
aspiration for 20 000 people and that
also includes their locally employed
staff so we are talking about this new
scheme in addition to the work that we
are doing with locally employed staff
another categories that will be included
in the repatriation flights that you're
seeing currently we're bringing back
almost a thousand people a day and when
it comes to locally employed staff we've
already brought over 2 000 people back
since june this year and we've had 13
charter flights bringing people back so
look this is an enormous effort but i
think also there are some really
important points to just highlight right
now for viewers we can't do this on our
own no country no government can do this
on their own so i spoke to my five eyes
counterparts last night we have to work
together
the americans clearly they are in
afghanistan they're working with us in
our military in terms of securing the
airport helping to facilitate people to
get them out of kabul get them out of
afghanistan and in our case take them to
different locations and then come to the
uk but the international community has
to work together on this and it's not
about one country saying we're going to
do x we're all working together to
really save lives and this is
effectively what we are doing with our
scheme but also recognizing the
international work that we're all
undertaking which locations
until they're coming out to separate
locations so america are using different
bases and different stations what do we
do so we're working we have a hub in
dubai so that is effectively where our
planes often stop to refuel where also
we do a lot of our additional checks we
have to check people before they come to
the united kingdom so that's
verification of documentation national
security checks are incredibly important
um as a government we must always ensure
that we are bringing over people that
have passed all national security checks
extension island so
that
this is we're talking about dubai right
now just in terms of the mod work which
other areas they might be coming to well
i don't not from not from our
perspective other countries and other
governments will do what they they will
do effectively and that's the matter for
them but from the uk perspective we are
bringing as you've seen the flights come
in
straight from afghanistan with
refuelling stops in places like dubai
straight over to bryce norton when will
the first plane carrying the afghan
refugees that we're talking about today
on this scheme when will they arrive in
the uk well we're working on that
because our priority right now is
british nationals we have to ensure that
we get all british nationals out of
afghanistan and alongside that we have
the locally employed staff and over the
last three weeks we've been adding to
categories as well of other individuals
who are vulnerable who are yes those
that have been locally employed not just
working with the military but but also
for example other categories um people
that have worked with ngos civil society
there are many many others including you
know family dependence so we've been
working very hard they have been our
focus and as i've already said kay our
plans right now they are being developed
because we have to ensure that we've got
the accommodation for them when they
come here and that also we have the
right civil society partners to ensure
that this scheme comes together when do
you anticipate the people that we're
talking about right now these african
refugees as part of the 20 000 in total
when do you expect the first of those to
arrive in the uk well we're working
through that right now i'm not going to
give you a date but we don't know at
this stage well it's not okay so you
don't know if you don't well actually
we're working through it so i'm not
going to give a date and a cup one out
of three we're working with partners and
you've already heard me saying there'll
be there'll be a call to local
authorities around the country and many
other partners that have experience i
think it's important to say as a country
we've done phenomenal work when it comes
to resettlement schemes when you look at
the syrian vulnerable persons scheme as
well that included community sponsorship
all sorts of third-party organizations
in communities that welcome reset um
refugees resettle them but also we have
to put the welfare support the education
support and all the other i can wrap
around support so get it that's what
we're working on okay so now so how are
we going to get these people out of
afghanistan given that the taliban say
that they don't want to uh any uh
afghans to leave the country well i
think are they not people that are in
afghanistan no this is an international
effort first of all i think we have to
we have to have some perspective here
we've all seen the scenes in terms of
what is going on on the ground this is a
very fluid situation we have military
forces on the ground and you know it's
the uk forces armed forces as well as
the us and there are other partners as
well we are working with in terms of
facilitating people to get them you know
through intercontinental
if well this is an international event
okay this is this is my point it's not
about the taliban saying that they're
not allowing us to take them because
that's inaccurate that is absolutely
inaccurate right now we are working
internationally through our past that's
what the taliban have said well the
talibans are saying certain things we
can see right now we're working on the
ground to get people afghan nationals
are on flights every single day okay
they are coming through they're landing
at bryce norton along with british
nationals so they are coming through it
is a logistical operation through
military partners and other partners on
the ground to ensure that we get people
out and there are plans in place to do
that so this is this is this is not this
is not clinical at all this is difficult
it is involving a lot of resource on the
ground
it's a very complicated fluid situation
but it's also a fluid situation
what about the afghan nationals who've
managed to leave the country and go to
third party countries like i don't know
pakistan will they be counted as part of
these 20 000. well look we're going to
work across the board and we're working
with all international partners so
you'll be very aware you've just raised
pakistan our prime minister
has already been in touch with imran
khan the prime minister of pakistan we
have to look at all of this now not just
from the i mean afghanistan is
incredibly important but regional
stability and security in the region so
pakistan does not want instability in
their own country so this is my point
about international cooperation and
collaboration we are working we are in
touch with all our allies it's important
that we are united
and coordinated in our collective
efforts to get people out not just of
afghanistan but people who need
protection people who are fleeing
oppression persecution whose lives are
at risk and that does take an
international effort okay let me just
say now the british government will work
with every partner to ensure that we can
do the right thing by those that need
our help and support exactly the taliban
well we have to work internationally in
terms of cooperation we'll work with all
our allies we'll work with all our
allies
to ensure you've already helped me speak
and reference certain countries so i've
mentioned pakistan i've mentioned canada
five eyes so i was speaking to my
five-year-old counterpart
well we we have to we have to work with
all partners partners international
partners i should say
that have worked in the region to bring
stability and security and to bring
protection let me ask about it we have
to continue to do that okay also hope to
see if i'm there we only have a limited
amount of time what about the afghan
nationals who've recently crossed the
channel and have found themselves
seeking asylum in the uk
could they be part of the 20 000 well
i'm speaking very specifically oh no
they're not if i if i can just without
jumping to conclusions curve i've
already said that we're working on this
scheme our priority right now with the
new scheme for the f 5000 specifically
we do want to prioritize women girls on
the most vulnerable persecuted
minorities when it comes to others that
have come through illegal migration
rules we will have to look at those
cases in a way in which we do anyway
through the asylum system we are
reforming the asylum system but there's
an important point to make here right
now when the world and when we see what
we are seeing in afghanistan when we see
heroin scenes when we know that there is
a humanitarian crisis unfolding in front
of us it's right that we create bespoke
routes humanitarian routes to protect
lives but those are governments that
fled across the channel and are now
seeking asylum from afghanistan they did
that you know of course there's a
distinction okay there is a distinction
between those illegal routes where
people have been trafficked through
um
gangs and criminal activities
if i may say so you won't know the
background to many of those cases and
these are people that have come through
illegally currently we are creating a
new bespoke scheme which rightly so
focuses on women and girls many of those
women and girls are minorities are
pushed aside as we have seen
historically in afghanistan but also
when it comes to claiming asylum in many
countries and if i may finally just say
on people that have come to the united
kingdom legally they're also traveling
through many safe countries through eu
member states and i am calling on all my
international counterparts other
interior ministers to work collectively
together with that responsibility on
this with that in mind you agree with
president macron that europe i'm quoting
him um can't bear the consequences and
we need to protect ourselves against
migration
well president macron you know will make
those types of comments you agree with
them well what i would say though
there is a crisis there is a
humanitarian crisis the united kingdom
is creating new humanitarian routes to
ensure that we can save lives and
protect people
within europe there is so much more that
the eu commission can do and could do in
terms of stopping irregular migration
and creating safe and legal routes and
to disagree with you to be very frank
i've also been
persuaded as persuading and speaking to
other eu member states over recent
months to effectively ask them to do
much more on the humanitarian side and
support the creation of safe and legal
routes which could stem flows
you were talking about the different uh
scheme as well that involves the
interpreters and third party contractors
johnny mercer one of your mps says that
the figure of 5000
doesn't even touch the sides he says
it's something like 20 000 people uh who
should be caught up in that scheme
how do we choose which 15 000 to leave
behind well i think first of all
this is we this is a scheme that has
been developed in conjunction with them
mod
and the home office ben wallace and i
have worked together on this and this is
a scheme that was announced in april and
as you've already heard me say since
june the 22nd of june um up until last
week we brought over 2000 people so
these are locally employed staff
and other countries are doing exactly
the same with les schemes now the mod
have their own processes they know
exactly who they've been working with
translators interpreters and there'll be
many others as well in terms of
resilient staff on the ground what i
would say is that the mod have been
incredible in terms of the scheme the
development of the scheme and we support
that obviously in terms of documentation
and giving people
the status recognizing them the checks
to then come to the united states
well actually
but if you've heard what i've said
already i'm listening to every step
that's that scheme has been expanded
yeah um so there are more categories
that so we don't there'll be more than
five thousand we're already seeing more
than ten thousand there could be up to
ten thousand but not twenty thousand so
they're happy up to the other ten so let
me just be clear about this there could
be up to ten thousand we are expanding
categories right now of people and we're
working with
the mod on the ground we're working with
partners on the ground to identify these
individuals and importantly so there
could be more than ten there could be
there absolutely could be and if you
think about the flights that we're
seeing on a daily basis with up to a
thousand people coming back you can see
that more and more people we are working
night and day
we have people we're being very fluid
and very flexible i'm sure johnny and
also in addition to that when you think
about the additional staff we've got the
mod the military teams on the ground i'm
sending in home office officials who put
border force officials
into the region to help support this
scheme as well okay so we're being very
fluid and we're recognizing the change
in nature and the landscape of what is
going on this is not clear-cut it's not
binary it's not clinical
i'm sure we're doing everything possible
to ensure that we can save lives and
recognize that there are many
individuals whose lives are at risk
right now because quite frankly they've
stood by us they've stood by our country
over the last 20 years and we are
working night and day to do the right
thing to try and protect them and bring
them to the united kingdom we're almost
out of time i know you have an awful lot
of people to talk to this morning so we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us let me ask you quickly before i let
you go um as a woman as well as a
politician but primarily as a woman you
heard what the taliban was saying
yesterday
how much of what they said did you
believe
well
not just particularly when it comes to
women well they were saying
let's let's let's put everything about
the taliban into context when it comes
to women and i have been to afghanistan
and i have seen how oppressed the level
of oppression that women and girls have
been subjected to in afghanistan
and look one of the strongest aspects of
all our work and the british
government's commitment and the
international community's commitment
over the last 20 years there's no
question being the work around women and
girls it's been extraordinary was it all
for nothing though we are doing the
right thing in my view through the new
routes that we are creating we're
putting women and girls and vulnerable
people first it will for anybody that
has served in afghanistan people and
also in the international community that
have been there they will totally
recognize just the level of oppression
the fear and persecution that women have
been subject to and girls and we want to
prevent that which is why you'll see
from the prime minister you'll hear from
the prime minister today and i worked
with i worked with the prime minister
when he was foreign secretary i saw the
commitment that he gave to women and
girls
in afghanistan and around the world we
stand by all the work that we have put
in place the protections and we are
committed to doing so much more so i
think you know the taliban's actions
were so emotional
i've seen it i've absolutely seen in
afghanistan the level of oppression and
persecution of women and girls and it's
unspeakable
are we doing the right thing by pulling
out our troops following the united
states well we are where we are okay
look we are where we are on all of this
and our objective right now as a
government is to save lives and do the
right thing when it comes to the
humanitarian approach that we take but i
think and i recognize this in many many
ways i've been to refugee camps in
jordan in lebanon we've seen the
conflict the level of conflict that
afghanistan the destabilization that we
have all witnessed over the last 20
years
it is appalling we want to save lives we
stand by that we stand by those women
and girls who've been subject to
oppression and persecution
and my final point is the international
community this is an enormous moment for
the international community it was only
you know seven eight years ago we saw
what happened in syria we have to work
together and as part of my own plea to
my colleagues within the five wise
community last night as well we have to
speak with one voice we have to work
together we have to support each other
no country can deliver
humanitarian support or support for
women and girls we can't do it on our
own we have to absolutely stick together
and work together to save lives and
protect protect those afghan nationals
whose lives are at risk